Jona by the former Foreign Secretary me
Hans hello to you thank you for joining
us on the program this morning I wonder
if I could put to you what I also put to
the former defense minister to by a
zealous about this planned assassination
of Salamone back in 2007 but the then
foreign sector II stepped in and said
that's the bad idea how do we look back
on that decision now I do you think well
I think it's probably a wise decision at
the time to do that you do have to make
these very difficult judgment calls in
government if I was asked a similar
question this time around I would have
wanted to know not just the the tactical
advantage of doing something like that
but the long-term strategy and I think
the issue for the United States has been
that people haven't really known whether
it wants to be involved in the Middle
East or not you got the signals like
last October pulling out of Syria
abandoning the Kurds a very strong
isolationist signal suggesting America's
a country that really wants to
disentangle itself from messy conflicts
in the Middle East and then you get
things like ripping up the Iran nuclear
deal the assassination of sulemani and
so people find it hard to know whether
america is is seriously engaged in the
region or not and that is dangerous
because then people make miscalculations
and I think that's what salami need did
I think he thought that he could carry
on with some of his regional plans and
projects and America probably wouldn't
react and how wrong he was as president
Trump's action been a dangerous
miscalculation only time will tell I
think it's easy to underestimate at the
moment
why could have been a bold move that
actually pays off because if there was
one person who was responsible for
regional instability in Lebanon in Syria
in Iraq in Yemen it was Silla mania he
was the hardline radical inside the
Iranian regime who had the air of the
supreme leader the politicians who I
dealt with his foreign secretary were
the moderates
we never got any access to Soleimani and
i wanted access to him because he was
the person who could have for example
got Nazanin freed and sent home he had
that power so it may be that he is
irreplaceable it may of course be that
the counter-reaction that we now get
from Iran is of such a nature that we
get a real plunge into very dangerous
instability so I think time will tell
where does that leave Britain well if
there's one country that does have some
influence with the United States its
Britain I think we shouldn't
overestimate that influence but we
shouldn't underestimate it either the
issue we've got is that there is a
growing contempt in Washington for
Europe generally including Britain
because they say that we're spending 4
percent of our GDP on defense and the
Europeans are spending at best 2 percent
and so you know what's their role what's
their relevance I mean they they like to
a pine they like to talk about human
rights they like to say oh this is
dangerous that was unwise but they don't
put their money where their mouth is and
so if we're going to do anything we
might as well do it alone and that's the
risk we have which is why I hope in this
fundamental defence and security review
that's happening this year we recommit
to being a proper serious military power
because I think if we do that we will
have a stronger voice in Washington and
that's much better for the world in the
meantime we've got a president who's
sabre-rattling on Twitter and
threatening to escalate the situation in
the Middle East how concerned are you
that war is on the horizon well I don't
think there will be a war because
neither Iran nor the US wants a war or
can afford a war but let me know
sometimes see both sides can stumble
into these things exactly and the risk
that we've got at the moment is that
both sides are under estimating the
resolve on the other side so suleimani
was with his Kurds forces planning his
projects in Iraq but also with Hezbollah
in in Lebanon and other parts of the
Middle East and his broad assumption I
think we can say now was that the u.s.
retaliate because it was basically
trying to withdraw from the region ahead
of president Trump's reelection
and he was wrong but the united states
have also been wrong in thinking that
their economic sanctions were going to
bring Iran to its knees they haven't and
indeed in some ways what's happened this
weekend will strengthen the regime in
Iran can I talk to you very briefly if I
may please about Brits who are in jail
there we know that you've done a lot or
tried very very hard to get nothing back
home to her husband also there is
another Brit Anusha a cherie
we spoke to his wife sherry a few
moments ago and this is what she had to
say I try to keep him updated with all
the positive developments that happen
obviously you know when you sitting in a
basement in prison several thousand
miles away it's very important to know
that people are active on your behalf
sometimes they it doesn't feel safe
where they are because a couple of
occasions some guards had told not just
my husband but a couple of other dual
nationals that we don't really see why
they keep you alive here you're all a
bunch of spies you're a bunch of
traitors and if it were up to us some of
us we would just take machine gun and
kill y'all
well I met Shari when I was foreign
secretary and she was one of the other
cases who at the time didn't want her
case to be publicized and so I've
obviously respected that but I was very
closely involved in in the case of
Anushka Sheree and I think he's a
remarkable man my judgement is that he's
wholly innocent like Nazanin he's being
held as a hostage it is desperately
unjust and I'm afraid what's happened
with the assassination of Salome Amy
will be a hammer blow to those who are
trying to get loved ones home because
everything Iran does now will be seen
through the prism of its relationship
with the West with the United States of
wanting to exact revenge and retribution
on Western countries for what's happened
and that of course makes it a much
tougher climate if you're trying to
negotiate something as sensitive as as
getting someone home from a foreign
sector II thank you very much indeed for
joining us we appreciate it thank you